[Music]
Wendy whoo homecoming warrior boy that's
a Disney Channel original movie title if
ever I've heard one this martial arts
team rom-com sounds absolutely
ridiculous and yeah this but it's also
surprisingly charming and funny and
actually kind of likable don't get me
wrong it's got some bad moments and some
laughably bad moments but we'll get to
them in a bit a teenage monk is sent
from his home to look for a reincarnated
Warrior assuring them he won't fail they
assure him that he's not the one he
needs to worry about for indeed this
ancient warrior is a teenage girl who
was more obsessed with becoming
homecoming queen than anything else when
the boy shows up he clearly doesn't know
how to blend in and she gets freaked out
by him well when an evil master
overlords something or other starts
taking over people's bodies and starts
using martial arts on everybody
she finally starts to listen to the boy
and he convinces her that she's the only
hope this of course means she has to
learn martial arts he has to learn the
wacky ways of blending in to be a common
teenager and they had to do all this
while preparing to be the homecoming
queen yeah you've heard this pretty
stupid story before it's kind of like
Kung Fu Panda meets High School Musical
and indeed a lot of this writing could
very easily be portrayed in an either
too corny way or too selfish way or
annoying way but thankfully the
direction really takes its time having
some quiet moments and some softer
moments and even some funny moments the
actors are all really likable and have a
really good chemistry off of each other
particularly in the family and even
though some of these characters are kind
of archetypes that played a little bit
more creatively the jerky kids in this
for example aren't just there to be the
jerky kids they're legitimately kind of
funny and goofy and I laugh at him every
once in a while I especially like this
one girl who also wants to be homecoming
queen but she doesn't do the typical
Disney bully thing where she calls her
names or anything it's all kind of these
passive-aggressive compliments that are
actually pretty funny
Wendy blew herself is actually kind of a
selfish character but again she plays it
with enough charm and relatability that
you're still for the most part on her
side and you laugh at her antics the one
point where it does start to get a
little much though is the climax first
of all there's a really dumb decision
made by the main character and after all
that we
watching her do and learn and stuff you
just don't buy it
they're always teaching her about her
destiny and kind of this end of the
world stuff and when you see the choice
she makes at first it's really not
believable but thankfully it doesn't
take long and we get to our big climax
and while the martial arts is pretty
cool in it there's a lot of silly stuff
for example the monster possesses this
girl and she has the deep monster voice
and a lot of times this thing is
actually kind of intimidating because he
goes from body to body and it's kind of
like it follows it's kind of creepy the
way that he or she or whoever it is it's
kind of following her but then when you
hear this girl talk with there's a
progressing voice it's just kind of
ridiculous on top of that a lot of
slow-mo in this movie it's actually
effectively done I feel like they show
the really cool stuff to slow down and
make it look impressive but the downside
is a lot of the time you can clearly see
the stunt people and they look nothing
like the actors look at this company
crop it just a little bit or not slow
down this part there must have been a
better way to edit this so that you
don't see that any other problems I have
are kind of nip digs for example there's
a scene where the boy offers them these
little pies and the father doesn't want
to eat them and we find out later it's
because he feels like he's a little
homesick and he realizes he should think
more about his Chinese culture and the
wife agrees and it doesn't go anywhere
Italy it's a nice scene because these
actors do it so well but from a writing
standpoint it doesn't really lead to
much once in a while - the boy can act a
little weird I don't know if his accent
is too thick or as inflections or a
little odd but honestly for the most
part he's pretty charming it works out
okay and like I said this movie does
surprisingly have a lot of charm I like
the creativity around a lot of these
scenarios for example the first big
martial arts fight is actually done in
silence because they don't want to wake
the girl up admittedly the boy should
want to wake the girl up so that she can
run away but this is still pretty funny
so yeah this isn't anything great before
a little movie with some martial arts
and a couple of jokes and likable people
I think it's totally fine it's a very
by-the-book story but as these
by-the-book stories go
I found myself legitimately enjoying it
and I think a lot of kids and even
grown-ups will too it's silly sure but
it's an enjoyable even kind of
impressive silly like I said the martial
arts it's pretty damn well done
especially for a Disney Channel
movie and I really like watching these
characters take a look and get a kick
out of it yourself